all right i saw the hunt in this
socially politically divided climate
this will be a fun one
let's talk about it
[Music]
the hunt so the hunts it's the newest
movie making a social political message
the premise is there's a group of people
they've been kidnapped they all wake up
in this field
somewhere and now there's another group
of people hunting them but in a world
where you have the movie at its baseline
entertainment factor and then you have
the message that the movie's trying to
get across
it's important for a movie to remember
that to its core people are coming to be
entertained well i mean not every movie
there are movies that are made to have a
message for message sake but a movie
like this you know what i'm saying
there's a movie about a group of people
who get captured and taken to this place
and they're being hunted down in this
hyper violent kind of quirky and funny
in part
people are coming to be entertained you
can't just lecture them and that's that
you have to entertain people and if the
movie doesn't remember that first and
foremost then you have just another
movie
one of the many that i've seen before it
that hopes that the message it throws at
your feet is enough to carry the movie
generally speaking that just makes the
movie forgettable not in this case
though the hunt was actually really fun
when people start getting picked off a
couple of the hits they're i wouldn't
say cartoony
but they're a little exaggerated the
hits they take are pretty damaging a bit
extreme i'm like
you should be dead not like if a car
runs over someone's head you're not
dealing with the looney tunes head
where's like hey my head's flat
it goes not like that couple of the hits
though i was like you should not be
talking right now so it's just
exaggerated enough to let you know that
you're dealing with a movie of extremes
i thought that was a smart way to
illustrate
that early on and entertaining who
doesn't love a good bloody hit it's a
little different than i thought it
really concentrates on one character
played by betty gilpin and she was great
in the movie i've never seen glow so
this is really my reference for her but
i thought she was good at carrying the
movie she's the main character so in a
world where you have a
fun intense rated r cat and mouse type
movie that keeps you engaged with that
entertainment premise we come to the
point the movie's trying to make with a
social political commentary funny enough
this just
actually kind of dawned on me as i'm
thinking about it right now initially i
was like oh clearly
those are the left-wing people and those
are the right-wing people but i can't
recall in the movie
anyone professing which side is which i
mean you make an assumption based on the
characters
that are in both groups and how they
interact but in the end maybe they do
say it and i just i can't recall i can't
remember when the movie starts out with
a text conversation of one side color
and the other one deplorables
you kind of you start to assume so
really the movie's more addressing
social conflict social strife rather
than
political granted social political the
lines get really blurry and the
conversation's among either
equally heated equally unenjoyable you
can say social political commentary but
really it's social commentary the kind
of conversations you've seen online the
kind of conversations you've seen on
twitter it actually addresses
a strong element of social media but
what the movie's trying to address
through that
is extremism and that applies to both
sides political spectrum social spectrum
extremism doesn't really
it's not conducive to solving a problem
it's entertaining
it gets you likes and retweets but it
doesn't help outside some things some
references were
a little on the nose in fact more than a
few words like they felt like if they
made a reference or a jab to one side
they had to do it to the other two to
balance the equation perfectly balanced
as all things should be the quote the
biggest masked murderer of all time in
cinematic history that we all
love we're dicks so in the name of
balance that they felt they had to do
sometimes you're like oh that
that was a little on the nose it happens
i won't say it doesn't but in the end
like i said to its core if you want to
just take the message
out of it if you're like social
political whatever entertain me the
movie is actually really entertaining it
has a strong lead character it's clever
it's violent it's bloody it's fun it's
intense the cat and mouse game is really
engaging the douchebags in the movie
they are dicks in a movie like this you
got to have some engaging douchebags
when you get dennis reynolds from it's
always sunny
he is one of them and he works and
actually has a really good kick ass
fight at the end of the movie hats off
to that fight that fight was
definitely a surprise the hunt i will
say was a good time no alcohol required
i saw the hunt have you seen it what did
you think about her what's your favorite
battle royale this is not really a
battle royale movie you know people
hunting other people
killing them hard target
do you like hard target comment below
let me know because it's pretty much our
target and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you